Speaker 1: Well, I told you that a lot of
people looked and sounded bored during Donald
Trump's big 2024 announcement. It turns
out that it wasn't just my perception.
People were trying to leave the room at Mar a
Lago last night, and Mar a Lago staff blocked
people from leaving the room. Understand
that the Trump announcement was so boring,
people were trying to get out and they were forced
to stay in the room. Here is ABC's Jonathan Karl.
Folks, this this is beyond parody. It is
stunning that this is the world we now
live in. Listen to this incredibly low energy.
Speaker 5: I actually saw people trying to leave
and people leaving early.
Speaker 1: And by the way,
Trump is speaking right now. He was.
Speaker 5: Down. He's still speaking
now. And then they, I think, perhaps a
little concerned that the hall the hall
would empty out too much. They actually
started preventing people from leaving.
Speaker 4: So now they're no longer allowed.
Speaker 1: What an electric atmosphere at Mar a
Lago where it's quiet enough for a reporter to do
a stand up while the speech is still going on. I
mean, think of that that that in and of itself
is amazing. And increasingly, of course, the
question is, has Trump fizzled out? The polling
is not looking good. DeSantis is leading Trump
in just about every poll, and Trump's not even
I'm sorry, DeSantis hasn't even announced that
he's running for anything yet. So the question
of whether Trump fizzled out is one question.
The speech really was very low energy, and at
one point the camera panned to Trump's family,
and they were all just kind of standing there
awkwardly. It wasn't even really clear they were
that into it. And there were some reports that not
everybody in Trump's family wanted him to do this.
Ivanka Trump, as far as was reported, wasn't even
at the speech. And we actually have video here.
I'll play this. You can see a crowd
milling from screen right to screen left,
and they're just quite literally blocked. There is
a bunch of staffers in the lower left preventing
anybody from getting out the the entire thing
was going to empty out and people were blocked,
security or whatever. These people are not letting
them leave. Forget about freedom of speech. They
don't even have freedom of movement at Mar a
Lago. So that was quite, quite remarkable. Here's
another moment of just how bored people were. This
was while Trump was speaking, and you see many
empty seats and just absolutely no energy here.
Speaker 4: They've devalued their currency,
whether it was the pound or whether it was the WAN
or the yen. Yeah. And I used to fight like cats
and dogs with the leaders of other countries.
Speaker 1: Like a dog.
Video at one point also caught Roger Stone.
This is pretty funny. Stone was there and I
can't think of anyone looking more bored about
all of this than Roger Stone. He looks like he's
wondering where the exits are or maybe the bar.
Speaker 4: And they let it go back up instead
of putting America. Last year, the
Biden administration has done very,
very openly and bravely.
Speaker 2: My God.
Speaker 1: What it really was like like Hotel
California. You can check out any time you want,
but you can never leave. And much of the crowd
mentally checked out, but quite literally not
allowed to leave. Just one more clip here just
to give you the flavor of what was going on.
One guy doing YMCA. Okay, Chuck, if you're
watching, look at the middle of the room.
He notices no one else is doing it. And
then he stops. So lower energy. Hard to
imagine. Trump didn't seem that into it. His
family certainly didn't seem that into it.
The crowd didn't seem very much into it. And
one of the most interesting aspects of this
was even Fox News didn't seem that into
it. And I want to talk about that next.